hello everybody
hope you are having a great evening or
any time of the day wherever you are um
today we
are hoping to look into
some full magnus games i am just waiting
to confirm that i
am on youtube i haven't accidentally
started streaming somewhere else okay i
think we are
on youtube and
let's see what else what else is new
yeah so we're gonna look at some magnus
games
and uh
per usual we are gonna do the switch to
twitch in about an hour
and just flip it see your games
see if you can play as good as magnus
there's there are some really really
cool magnus games
but i wanted to kind of look into
something
that potentially we haven't really i
mean it's not that famous because last
week we looked at the anan magnus match
and that's pretty famous
so my hopes for this week's game is so
that no one knows it so everything's
pretty fresh
um but the truth of a bit behind it
is um two different things
number one um wanna this is a game that
i included in the book that i read with
my brother which will be
out by end of summer but
the other part of it is that one of my
kids
asked me about if i ever play this as
black
and i was like i've actually never ever
played this as black so i started
looking
into um this opening just a little bit
and i saw oh magnus had a cool game and
that's we included this in
the book so um that's
the reasoning behind why i'm showing you
this game
oh perfect thank you var it's very sweet
of him
did you guys know he's my team coach
yeah
i haven't had the chance to work with
him often this semester because i'm um
i'm cat
pain but um yeah
he's he's one of the coaches it's him
and alejandro
my two musketeers really the third one
making the three musketeer
peachy is sunbathing it is extremely
warm and humid in seth lewis so
kishi is not really having it he goes
out
he meows he comes back like he meals at
me like why is the weather like this
art yeah everybody loves war who doesn't
love her
all right um okay
so uh unfortunately i do show the name
because
i wa i wanted to initially be like maybe
i should make you guys guess
who played it but if you want you can
guess which tournament was this
uh it wasn't like a super well actually
it was a strong tournament but not one
of the super tournaments
all right so yeah this was a very very
cool game
and the magnus kind of just crushed this
poor
uh story i actually think i know this
guy
um it's been years but i he i believe he
is indian and he was a grandmaster
few years older than me but i remember i
always saw him in like the the world
juniors or like asian
championships nope not regular
yeah all right so obviously take is the
main logical move and as you can also
guess from the title of the
today's show it's gonna be a bunch of
sacrifices
and um so
first question who who likes knight f6
who wants to take those are your two
logical options let's go with that
and yeah that's june was also kind of a
i had this idea that in the month june
i'm gonna just talk about magnus in
chess and psychology
because he has so many cool games and um
i want to kind of have like a tiny video
series on him
um so we've done few before and we're
gonna try and do
the june june month of magnus and the
fun part is
june in farsi like the word june means
deer
i guess it could like if you make it
sound
it could also be delicious these games
are very sacrificial so
but now mainly it's like um dear blah
blah
so june can be that yeah different gym
yeah and so in the thumbnail i started
texting ben simon the producer like hey
can we have this
word june and um in the thumbnails in
the picture
and he was like sure let's see how that
works and i think it works kind of nice
maybe next time i can have fireballs
throwing it
yeah oh c6 i've actually never really
encountered this
um i mean i understand the logic line do
you want to get your pieces out quickly
but i i mean i don't think c6 is a very
quick high level um chess
var ism
yeah so i like this knight f6 idea
uh i think queen d5 is also i mean very
logical it's there's nothing wrong with
taking
especially since um something like you
just
like there's so many not queen six i
know
oh queen d6 there's so many different
ways of playing it and i think it's just
a
good idea but uh knight f6 is much
sharper
and so after knight f6 this d4 idea
is the best one for those of you who
have played against me
you probably do know that i've played
this bishop
e5 line a lot and i think it's a cool
idea to play in like shorter time
control
so if you are interested in this bishop
b5 idea i strongly suggest you
give it a try it's definitely worth it
but
if you are more uh
yeah thank you thank you i i did not
catch war's
stream sorry i was trying to clean up a
little around
but yeah i tried to make the wall all
white backgrounds because i usually have
stuff on my background but
yeah if you look at this other wall i
have physics equations here
and if you look at a little farther down
the road i have
a biochemistry stuff so um
not it's not this was kind of the only
white spot on the house that i haven't
filled up with papers on the walls
yeah ah i'll be free end of the month
of this torturous exam um
let's see
all right so yeah this bishop b5 i think
is quite a nice idea
i did see that the the inside dm i'll
look into it more but
until end of june i am a zombie
like a little zombie trying to wake up
every day 5 a.m so far i've managed to
make it to 7 a.m well i guess we'll
increase the stamina
all right so i'm a big fan of bishop b5
i strongly recommend you look into the
theory of it i think it's interesting
it doesn't really grant you like a cool
advantage but if your opponent is caught
off guard you can at least end up with
time advantage
so definitely look into it however
magnus's opponent kind of trusted his
opening knowledge and he just went for
d4 main line
you're already giving up the extra pawn
back
but you get to continue developing c4
is doable but i'm not really i'm not a
big fan of it neither is my brother
um yeah so i like the we both like this
d4
idea and uh there is this
thing um with i'm not a big fan of but i
guess c6 is also a recommendation but
that's not mike what magnus mentor he
simply went for bishop g4
which is already a little um clever
than usual so uh
one thing that i wanted to mention oh
yeah taking is definitely doable too
but it could be followed by either c4
then boom you bring the knights out
quickly or just simply bring this knight
out
easy development and then eventually
you're gonna do the c4
so uh it's just a matter of time
[Music]
oh yeah i like this i i want to do more
magnus videos
hopefully like i want to try to see how
this works if
how the viewers like it because if you
guys like it then we could just kind of
um have mini video series on uh
different cool chess players
so i'm i'm testing the waters with
magnus if it goes well
july we can have nepal or i've done a
few videos on fobby so
we'll see all right
okay uh rahul that is not an arabic word
that
is a persian word the alphabet is very
similar so i
understand the confusion all right so
we're still in the opening phases i
don't think this is a super popular
opening
unless you play this um so it's
understandable if
most of us are not very comfortable with
what's going on here
so another tiny pause why to move what
should white do
you have few choices move the queen try
to exchange the bishop
just ignore it get the knight out or go
for something like f3
and i can already feel like as soon as i
said f3 everybody want what
because that's what
that's the usual response that i get
whenever i mention the word f3
after is so underappreciated
exactly see never play f3
ah no live thank you i actually did
when i started teaching i was more
comfortable talking about my games at
the beginning
so i did talk about a lot of my own
games
so there is kind of a video series out
there like that and then i did like
opening series and then after that i
started doing more classics
mixed with openings so definitely yeah
it's usually easier to talk about the
games that you played personally
yeah basically i guess ben feinkel just
had a minute twitch when i said
f3 so any any votes anybody wants f3 i
know
i know how this looks i know after is
not the one that you want
but sometimes you just gotta settle is
after
it though
i think yes unfortunately uh knight t2
is another
possibility you can just bring out the
night and then continue by like getting
the other night out but it's a little
passive so i'm not really
recommending this uh bishop exchange is
also
not very uh recommended either
especially because if we
end up in this type of positions you
kind of are forced to do this like
knight f3
and then let's say like pawn push
and like c4 it's doable but you
shouldn't exactly do that
uh-oh i oh
i started the tiny uh wound somewhere
all right so f3 it is bishop gotta move
and
oh my god i'm sorry i forgot to mention
at the end of the line that i just
talked about
if we played with night bishop e2 take
if we take with queen or
knight eventually black is gonna long
cast though i forgot about that part
i am so sorry i don't mention that yeah
and yep sorry sorry sorry
yeah so f3 bishop gotta move and now
what
are we gonna chase this bishop or is
that too crazy
i kinda actually like the chase
magnus didn't do the chase yet
but definitely something that
is being considered
i think g4 is cool but what else what
else do we have do we need to do
well let me join a move in there do we
want to play something like c4
defending the pawn
uh tyler that is not arabic that is far
c because i'm pershing so i kind of
wanted to have a persian word in there
and
also the word june because uh june
in farsi means deer but
it's also the month june so i tried to
do the tiny word play in there
because why not wordplays are fun
so that's the thing at this point i
think the development
idea is that that ship sailed a little
bit
so what else do we have handy
i like c4 too right c4 just kind of
feels natural
okay maybe it's not natural but
definitely pretty cool
oh thank you tyler you too i like c4
let's do it
magnus did the c4 as well after c4
uh black simply went for e6 black's
still
upon dawn so pawn down so you're kind of
probably just simply trying to develop
nothing wrong with development right
development is our best friend
so
um now but the other question is shall
we take oh
squirrels should we get the knight out
should we
push over here you have a bunch of
options and
what do you think white should do now so
magnus is
still pushing but what do you think is
going on
still pushing is not the right word he's
trying to create
holes in black's position in white's
position
so this e6 is another cool thing
why not bring out the bishop first we do
we do want to bring out the bishop
um oh you're probably maybe bishop g5
it's doable if bishop g5 will probably
just
bishop b7
so what do you think about take knight
c3 is also pretty cool
but we can definitely take that eat the
pawn back and if you play g4
now i'll just bring my bishop back you
push i'll just move the knights you take
and i'll just bring this guy out too
white is up a pawn
uh but that
is not exactly i mean the position is
not very pleasant
so what about the take over here d
take c6
so let's say take now what do we do we
have options we got to take it back
or we can you know just ignore it and
develop
magnus is black yes
so
i had too many pawn moves oh 27
it's interesting but there would be a
bishop
d3
potentially or just a knight c3 i mean
white would just develop
so what do you think magnus should do
here
i also don't necessarily like having to
play king f7
so i completely understand wanting to
simply take it back
however if you simply take it back it's
too plain something like knight e2 is
possible
knight c3 is possible and
it can be simply followed by like
development in the kings
the queen side and then you're gonna get
a chance to start thinking of what to do
in the king side as well
i think this is fine it's okay there's
nothing wrong with it
but think of something more spicy
anything more spicy
now michelle v6 is not spicy at all
you just like you know gets the night
out you already moved the bishop here
and then you came back and then you came
back ah
oh spicy knight c6
yeah nice now that we got some spice in
here
take okay we gotta take it back
and magnus is not really scared of
leaving this king on f7 so
where does that leave us
[Music]
uh huh
yeah i like this idea yeah so
white's going to develop right so
eventually
like black wants to do this check bring
the rook and enjoy the game
but um white kind of messed it up i mean
sorry
not that messed up there is a little
white's development is really messed up
so in order for whites to be able to
actually
um develop white's gotta
start closing up the king pretty fast in
the game
story played bishop e3 which was a
mistake
how knight e2 would have been much
better and after
knight's e2 we could simply what do you
guys think we could do
92 is white's best move why do i keep
mixing up fools white who's black
yep knight b4 you guys got it good job
knight to g3
and then we could do this check king
moves and we could easily eat this pawn
yeah black's still doing pretty fine if
you try to be a
cute psychic it's fine i'll just take
back now there's another check coming up
even if the queens are exchanged that's
perfectly fine black is
still like plus two yeah
so uh in the game
he played bishop e3 now what i think we
should do after this bishop e3 bishop e3
is already kind of getting a little
messy
so
what do you think
why not yeah that was a good question 92
first of all
uh protects the potential rookie 8
checks
second of all itself is protected third
of all is defending over here
um so i like this idea of just getting
my pieces out
quickly so how can we get pieces out
quickly
what do you guys think is it time to get
out the bishop
yep let's get that out and white's gonna
have a bunch of troubles after here
because
um you cannot
exactly play this bishop d2 if you play
bishop d2
i'll simply take over here
and if you take there that's a nice
check and bye bye queen
you can't exactly do kinky two either
because
uh there i can easily just check here
or i can even check with queen and then
go over here that should be checkmate
soon
all right yeah and then you lose your
queen that way
so bishop d2 is not the way to go how
about knight c3 what would we do
in knight c3
basically rip queen i don't know if i
should read that as rip or rip
[Music]
yep let's bring out the rook now this
guy's under attack you come up here now
this guy is dropping
i could take it to the knights too but i
think this is just much more pleasant
because i'll just eat stuff for free
i like free stuff there we go
oh this should be very pleasant stuff
coming up
even if 92 i could just exchange over
here and
all these babes are about to become
snacks
nice nice romania cool
who is the boys
all right so that's how this is going to
go down now after bishop b4 why is only
kind of left with king f2
so now after king f2 now what happens
now what happens what do you think we
should do here
first of all i forgot that i had tea so
i gotta do that
yep that's cool t like that you gotta go
i'll reload on my teeth over
break
oh there are no real restrictions there
so i mean you can just
go for the tournaments ah cool
i thought they weren't really allowing
spectators
yeah because i know that they're still
figuring out the details on spectators
on big air tournaments because obviously
everybody wants to go but obviously
nobody wants to you know
be unsafe but so they're still
figuring a lot of stuff out so i didn't
know they were doing
spectators that's so cool yeah so let's
get the pieces involved jerky eight
gotta come out we were already
discussing this
and rook e8 move um
yeah now what do you think tonight what
should do probably gonna get the night
out right
now this already is a little
like smelly oh that reminds me of the
smelly cat salt
from friends yeah so this position is a
little smelly
what do you think is gonna go on now
okay that's cool at least you can watch
yeah
so what does this position smell of
that's kind of the bigger question
so
is bishop c2 and move ah
i mean maybe but
well if you want to do rook e3 why don't
you just do it now
exactly yeah that's what the physicians
thinks of
sacrificial stuff
so the smell of sacrifice now what do we
do
good stuff right let me just go back a
little bit
just one move to give you guys another
second to
get the feel on the position
so how's the feel feeling good on it
does ricky make everybody happy
because it does make me very happy it
would be good if i also had tea but
yeah so that's the good stuff
let's take this bad boy over here and
bam
as my brother also confirmed the bam
yeah so we got the spam
and carlson finds this cool idea of
course
and then there is a bunch of more
sacrifices to come
as the title has it sacrificial magnus
let's go
and so well i mean you kind of gotta
take it back but this is already lost
see this f3 is already kind of giving
white the creeps
and now what do we do where is the next
sacrifice
i kind of liked the bishop c2 idea
but i don't know if i would have done it
in the game because there are other
sacrificial ideas too
so i'm gonna give you guys a minute uh
instead of giving me a one la
one move if you can give me like uh at
least like a tree mover like i do this
you do that i do this you do that then i
do that
i think that would make me much happier
ah nice g4 i mean i feel like that's
something that will
surely come up but right now
so i like knight d4 i think knight g4 is
something that could potentially be
interesting
i kind of like queen e2 queen e7 what
about this bishop c2 maybe let's talk
about this bishop c2
another second
is this bishop c2 feeling good for
anybody
i did i mean to be fair bishop c2 is not
the move that magnus played in the game
but
it is a very very interesting
i do think is actually the strongest
strongest idea if bishop c2
now let's say uh queen d2
then we could do this super duper knight
g4
this is a computer line that i'm not
coming up with these on spots just to
clarify
so
now what
what will happen next
probably gotta take it right okay what
after
take
what change in the position what piece
can we
include now
oh yeah let's get oh sorry oh yeah let's
get the queen going
king moves boom king moves and you lose
the queen awesome and
should be checkmate soon enough all
right so let's say you don't take it you
play king e2 then what do we do
so
uh 94 definitely interesting but why
let's just get the queen
involved now your king has
nowhere to go and that's the beauty of
it you gotta bring this knight and i'll
just eat your queen voila
what about this weird move of king f4
what's then
what do we do now any cool checks any
piece that's not working
honestly i kind of want point f6 but
as cool as that might look we have a
better idea
what else to do
yep let's do this bishop d6 now king
takes over here and now what this is
again this is a very cool winning move
um to be fair queen d7 does hold
considerable advantage
but you have something much stronger
what is that something much stronger
that you have
oh h5 ah i think h5
the king kind of runs and you're a
little checklist because like if you
can't play g4 and run with the king
you're gonna have issues
you're like running out of pieces yep
bishop f5
now if you take it well let's talk about
king h5 first king h5's checkmate in two
moves
can you tell me what's king h5
yeah you got it checkmate is there and
if you just take it oops and if you just
take it
checkmate in three moves you could also
to be fair do h5 to take this away and
that should be checkmate too
but now where is your checkmate almost
there
starting with g6 not exactly ideal
because
i can't try to run away
so what now
so we said he wants to run away so how
do we stop that
exactly thank you queenish4 and then
we're going to continue with g6
bring the rock and where's the checkmate
this is a very very cool checkmate
i know you guys can find it just
where is my checkmate
yep you guys got it awesome night before
voila
perfect so that's why this bishop c2
line would be
so weirdly cool but we kind of missed it
um we found it right mike has missed it
he went for another super cool sacrifice
of knight d4
again queen e7 would have been playable
as well
but knight d4 is pretty cool right
now kate first of all tell me what is
wrong with take
ah thank you rika yeah then check king
moves and then bishop c5 yep you
got it thank you for answering my
question before i fully asked it
all right lovely and if king goes to
uh d2 we have rook d8
that wins the queen as well and
as rekka correctly said if king goes
up we are also going to
have bishop d6 is definitely doable too
but right now we have checkmate in five
move
do you guys want to try and find that
so
not exactly a a4
square is kind of related in a weird way
to your suggestion
checkmate and five moves
yep kind of starting to show it uh-huh
yep that's the line oh yeah
that's just the best one the knight is
five take
check and check and voila
yeah this isn't too hard to find
honestly but if you started bishop d6
you're again
going to able to find checkmate just a
little bit longer
all right so what about so after tank
opponents realize that okay i'm getting
in some hot waters or
hot pickles i guess so let's not take
that then he just ran away with the kink
now what do we do
i definitely do like bishop c5 bishop c2
also another cool idea but yes
bishop c5 is what magnus played he's
kind of preparing for all kind of
nasty discovery checks i'm quoting my
brother
and yes um that is what they're going
for
so now white's got to figure out in the
game white went for knight
a4 to try and deal with these but what
if king g3 what if you're just like i'm
gonna pack
my bags and leave wait that was a song
like that that i recently
recently listened to pack your bags and
leave
who said whose song was that
anyways yeah so king g3 where do we go
now
oh this is a nasty chick so basically
right now there's checkmate in three
moves it's quite
actually yes that's the best way to
explain it it's a nasty checkmate
knight h5 is also nasty but it's four
move checkmates
can you see it in three moves
knight h5 would work you gotta go to f2
you're gonna move this guy over here and
that should be it
but also also on my t2 is pretty cool
and the knight h5 and that'll be it
all right cool
okay so knight g3 kg3 doesn't work what
about knight
a4
i'm well i'm going after this guy so
what should we do should we just go for
the
plan that we already had
or we could just come and defend this
guy i think that's also good
but yeah bishop c2 makes a little bit
more
um
oily actually like spoiling
blood
oh that was dark yeah i like this bishop
see too
um yeah you're starting to just go at it
with the queen
and in the game white was just like you
know what
i'm done with this and he just took on
c5
however you can't really do anything
with your queen if you trying to run
with the queen you are going to just
lose this guy
and future issues for the queen as well
so there's not much
uh hope of trying to keep this
queen on board anyways so might as well
just
get yourself into this position
alright so now what so now
we know black has clear advantage now
it's just a matter of how is going how
he's going to use it
material wise white has a bishop
a rook and a pawn in exchange for the
queen so
if you look at it from like just purely
material wise
why it's fine right but advantage-wise
and the king-wise and objectively
and logically and everything except for
matt white's pretty
messed up so
how do we continue that how do we put
white and even more pickle
i kind of want pickle i have olives
mm-hmm yeah so let's just continue this
we don't want to lose this knight we
want to keep our pieces
active we're going to get the strip
coming in i don't really like this pin
so let's that's one thing that i've
realized that's kind of more
psychological part of this
chess aspect is that
yes you want to be able to
keep your cool and you want to be able
to you know
actually actively attack but now that
the dynamic of the position is changed
that cool two bishops that you have is
black you don't really have them anymore
so the but you have like you exchanged
your advantage
you uh like transferred your advantage
you had the different type of advantage
now your advantage is more
uh material wise and you have an extra
clean that you got to try and use
so one thing that i would strongly
recommend is even the choice
try to take like a minute break just get
up take a quick walk
think of a song drink water whatever
come back and then start thinking
well actually if it's online tournament
you can't exactly do that but you get my
points like
in a perfect world if this is the game
that you're playing
just um make sure to
not ignore the the differences that the
position has
right now then it had like five moves
ago so
and this is quite funny because this is
just move 15
and white is already pretty roughed up
yes matthew i kind of yeah that was kind
of the the idea to see um
how much my persian viewers would like
that
yeah so let's go 27 queen e7 might not
be
the strongest one you might have like
some cool knight g4s blah blah but you
don't need that
now it's about kind of chilling relaxing
and figuring out how to continue all
right so first of all let's not
get spinned let's go attack that guy uh
in the game a white played b4
white's trying to still be active but
now what do we do he still wants to eat
this i don't necessarily want to have to
move it but if i do that's also okay
because i can
start building up on here oh
says something went wrong
oh no am i still here because
okay i am still here my tablet
went cuckoo bananas for a second all
right we are good
move yeah yep just recreate
start to build on threads
and if you take it that will be fun
checkmate
and i could make tea faster but
in the game white just went for bishop
d3
trying to still develop check you can
move it
now what do we do here there is another
like
cool sacrificial idea but
not necessarily the most humane
one uh so
i'm gonna leave it up to you
ah honestly i think b6 could also work
but anything cool
oh maybe i want my i think i did mean to
say human
maybe i should save you a woman instead
of human
no i like this uh g5 yep g5 is a cool
idea and knight g4 is even better i
think
those two like that idea is just so
just nasty honestly because knight g4
like you have this extra material so
i to me when you have like extra like
material
and extra um like that mini advantage
even if you still uh try to
continue to push and sacrifice to me
that's such a
cute thing not not many people do it
honestly so knight g4
if take check if here boom boom bam
and you eat that that'll be a cool thing
too
so uh if now b6
b6 was in the game nothing wrong with
that he
uh suri went for knight e4 boom boom and
c5 magnus is taking a very strategic
approach he's not
trying to uh make the game messy he's
just he has a cool outpost he's using
that he has a very active queen
using that why not take and now
i gotta ask black to
what to do do we wanna just take it back
or do we wanna make it even more spicy
aha let's eat this guy yep the last
sacrifice
take and boom check and
if knight goes to f3 we could simply
make this work and wherever you go
uh i'll follow i'll eat the other word
you go over here i'll eat the other one
you go over there i'll eat the other one
yeah this is such a cool geography um
geometry problem yeah
all right so king e1 now what
now let's eat this one king f2 now what
do we do
so it's now clean to two pieces
so
two rooks sorry not two pieces now what
where do we go from here
i'll give you a little bit more
background from this game
so this game was actually played in 2018
and it was in the protest league so if
you couldn't figure out where this game
is from
that's perfectly fine because it wasn't
in like a it was protesting as a very
strong tournament
but uh it's not like it's not like
the like the grand chester is not like
that
so it's a little different format
definitely
yeah queen c2 came down and where did we
go now
this move i thought was just kind of
brutal
so what did i do after queen c2
what do you think
i think when you do is cool but if you
take you have to deal with this takes
two
how about so that's kind of i feel like
that's coming up but
maybe let's first deal fix this and take
this yeah let's take this first then
here actually white resigned because you
can't touch the knight because that will
be checkmate
and next move white's gonna have to deal
with these
stuff and nobody wants to deal with that
even if you try to be all
cute i'll just check you and then i can
just actually i kind of want to do a
nice seat now
also i really want this like there's so
many things that i want
or or or just this
and if you move the king i'll eat over
here this is like plus six
white doesn't really have much to do he
can try to prolong it a little but it's
not gonna change the result
so that's yeah i really like this game
uh this game was
a lot of sacrifices from magnus and the
opponent was just kind of
helpless just yeah that was a very um
sad game yeah so that is
how you take an advantage from this
lake it king if you're not present here
last week i suggest you go watch the
last week's stream
because i explained the concept of lake
it because it's
lonely and naked that's the best kind of
kink
so um so i'm hoping to do like a cool
mini series on different players so if
you like this video make sure to like
subscribe
share all those fun stuff and now i'm
going to take a short break and go
on twitch to analyze your games so in
about 10 minutes or so
please be present in twitch we're going
to be there for two hours so if you see
this video in an hour
we're still going to be there come by
and give us your
game make sure to have it on a vhs
format
we work on leeches mainly now actually i
don't know
what do we ever do in chess.com but
everything we do right now is only chess
basically so pick a game from
bleachers give me that cool leeches
and yep that's actually
yeah no life that's the lesson of today
the chestnut psychology
lesson for today was blake it
and on that high note i'm gonna do the
segment of switch to twitch
see everybody